James is in Florida hi James welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave how you
doing better than I deserve sir how can
I help all right I just discovered last
weekend I'm currently in baby steps -
I'm about $47,000 in that and I'm living
a little bit above my means in terms of
expenses only I don't have much that 10
in a month now I I leased a truck last
year that I'm currently upside down on
so I guess my question is should I take
out money to make up the difference
between the amount I owe on the truck
and just go to some other car to get rid
of the monthly payment or should I just
wait to the end of the week be rid of
the truck how much time is left on the
lease expires unit 2021 18 months yes
sir give or take probably more like 20
months okay and how much is your truck
payment or your lease payment at least a
minute 470 a month okay and so have you
done any research on the car as to what
it's worth yes sir the freedom value is
around 23 and then the private value is
around 26 okay and have you called the
leasing company to find out what the
early buyout is if you want to pay for
pay it off today yes there would be
thirty thousand okay so you're $4,000 in
the hole if you sell it today does that
sound right yes okay and your payment
times 20 is just under $10,000 right now
old 9800 if I were to make the rest of
the payments really just under $10,000
and so point being if you keep it you're
gonna be out $10,000 if you sell it
you're gonna be out $4,000 yeah that
gives you your answer okay and then just
get a beater car in the meantime yeah
yeah
what's your household income $47,000 a
year okay Garrity and how much other
debt have you got um I said to have
27,000 of Steel loans have a motorcycle
oil
1700 on a credit card it will reach out
on almond and have a personal loan for
my dad for about 5,000 okay all right
and so what are you 27 26
that's about right that's about about
where you would stand with that mess you
made
okay all right so yeah you got some
cleaning up to do you gonna be working a
lot and you're gonna be driving a car
that it's not gonna make you popular
yeah and oh well because if you keep
this car it is really gonna hold you
back yeah I would borrow the $4,000 in
about 2000 borrow 2000 more I'd rather
you be $6,000 in death and $30,000 and
$26,000 in debt so I got rid of $20,000
in debt this one move and put you into a
hoop deep you're on beans and rice rice
and beans you're not gonna see the
inside of a restaurant unless you're
working there and you're working all the
time now extra jobs anything you can do
to make money and on top of your 47
because you've got about another 40 in
debt to clean up right yeah okay and so
if you live on nothing and let's just
say you earn an extra $15,000 okay and
you live on nothing and you put that
whole 15 and another 10 I'd be 25 on
this debt you'd be debt-free in about 18
months yes sir but that's zero life okay
you're not gonna have a life all you do
is work and pay debt but you'll be free
once you're done and you get the rest of
your life to be smart yet there every
time I do something stupid I go if I
just do that though if that's the last
time I do it it was probably worth the
tuition to that class you know if you
just keep doing the same stupid stuff
over that's what makes you mediocre or
worse than that broke but so you've
learned and if you just put a stop to it
and say that's it we're done boom we're
done we're out of here I'm cleaning this
mess up then you'll go win